the numbers behind this story are very
grim and increasingly we're learning
they may be telling an incomplete story
now the Office for National Statistics
reports the number of recorded deaths
every week for the latest week recorded
the 14th week in the year up till April
the 3rd 16,000 387 people have died now
while not all of those workover deaths
if you need any further evidence of the
severity of this crisis just look at how
that compares to the weekly deaths so
far this year the bars there show every
week back to January and the line shows
the 5 year rolling average that latest
bar is a huge jump and it's actually the
highest weekly total since the ONS
started compiling this data all the way
back in 2005 now 21.2% of those deaths
had covered 19 mentioned on the death
certificate let's compare the total
number of deaths to those released by
the Department for Health and Social
Care at the time you can see while the
trend is very similar there is that big
gap there between those two lines now
according to the ONS there were six
thousand two hundred and thirty five
deaths in England and Wales by April the
third but at the time that lower line
there the government only reported just
over four thousand so why this big gap
and what does it tell us well firstly it
demonstrates the delay in reporting but
also it tells us something about the
gaps in the government numbers if we
take for example the deaths registered
by April the third 4122 just 90 percent
of those happened in hospital leaving 10
percent 406 there to be exact that
happened in the community now 217 of
those deaths were in care homes 136
happened within people's homes
33 were in hospices 3 were in other
communal places and 17 were described as
having happened elsewhere so far only
hospital deaths have been included in
the government numbers now if we bring
back that first column that showed the
latest weekly death numbers the concern
here is not just those Cova deaths that
have caused the jump in the
numbers above that five-year average but
it's also the other deaths there's a
chance that some of those extra deaths
there could have happened as an indirect
result of the pandemic perhaps people
not presenting at hospital when they
should be as the crisis continues sadly
we may not have seen the worst of its
effects